look i think they have to work it out i
i love what ron desantis has done here
in florida and as i say as i always tell
all my neighbors i'm here to keep
florida florida
i think it's fairly obvious that trump
is going to run but what my hope would
be
is that they have a sit down it doesn't
need to be something that we all have to
know about but they come to some
agreement whether it's going to be that
desantis will be the vp and trump will
just ram this thing through one more
time for one more term because he's
getting up there in age as well or
whether i don't know exactly what it is
but i don't think it matters the point
is that either one of them will be
significantly better i think that trump
obviously has his pluses which are that
he is trump and the energy around him
and all of those things but there's
minuses too uh related to how much the
machine hates him and and all of the
chaos that it'll unearth desantis has
almost all
positives uh but he has to work it out
with trump and if if guys like us can do
anything it's that we can talk about
that honestly and then hopefully they
will realize hey there's got to be a sit
down at mar-a-lago it'll be a lot more
pleasant than when trump had to do it
with mitt romney and let's see what
happens yeah no hostage videos from that
one obviously and look you know
ronda sanders can get re-elected he can
finish out his term in florida i don't
know about vice president because that's
kind of a thankless job but maybe
secretary of state or something like
that in the trump administration but
again this is a good problem for
republicans to have and it's the
opposite problem that democrats have
dave always great to see you we'll see
you on the internet and in bookstores
everywhere great to talk to you
good to see you my friend if you're
looking for more honest and thoughtful
conversations about politics instead of
non-stop yelling check out our politics
playlist and if you want to watch full
interviews on a variety of topics watch
our full episode playlist all right over
here and to get notified of all future
videos be sure to subscribe and click
the notification bell